[Music]
thank you and for that intro I
appreciate it and as she mentioned I'm
an engineer at our studio and this is
going to be an expanded version of the
talk I gave at our studio account so I
can provide more detail on working with
api's and arm we will begin with an
overview a quick review of the Web API
basics move on to tools for accessing
those api's I have a couple of examples
prepared and a practical application
that we have built in-house using these
techniques and at the end I'll give you
some resources for finding or finding
out more information if you're
interested in expanding your knowledge
in this area so API basics there are a
lot of data accessible over the Internet
these days and a lot of it is made
available via API s which are
application programming interfaces these
allow programs to talk to each other
based on a communication contract if you
ask me a question in a way I understand
I will give you an answer so there are
two important parts to HTTP
communication over the web
there's the request which is data sent
to the server from the client and then
the response which is the data that the
server sends back to that client now
this is a very oversimplified view of
the client-server communication but the
basics of it are ask a question and get
a response and this is predicated on the
fact that the client and server need to
understand each other's language so to
speak the client can send can only send
a request to the server that the server
knows how to handle and then the server
will send that response back to the
client and the client will need to know
how to parse that response to get the
data out based on the question that was
asked web api's usually provide read
and/or write access to data stores when
you're talking about web api and they
allow you to access data on an ongoing
basis this is significant since it
allows you to write scripts
that poll and API to get the most
up-to-date data not only way your
analyses be current but when the data
changes your scripts don't have to
depending on how you design those
scripts data frames and plots will
update automatically when your data
changes without you having to download a
new CSV or import data manually so as an
example of this request response I've
put down here a curl request curl as a
utility in the in the UNIX world that
allows you to make HTTP requests in this
case I'm calling the OM db-api this is
the online Movie Database API and I'm
giving it a request with a query
parameter key for title and R for
response format so in this case I'm
saying om DB give me the data for the
titles a movie named clue and send it
back to me in JSON format the server
understands this request because you put
it into the format that it expects and
so it sends a response that contains the
data you asked for the title of the year
the rating etc again this is a very
simplistic example but it gives you an
idea of sort of how it's simple it is to
ask a question and receive an answer and
pull that data into the scripts that
you're writing everyday web api's are
organized into resources that often that
are often in a particular hierarchy in
this example there's a map that if you
follow down from the top you can get
information about accounts a particular
campus ID the lists that a particular
account has the ID of those lists the
campaigns the subscribers the web forms
etc so these are often organized in maps
or webs of information and if you know
how to get to those different levels of
information you can construct a URL and
ask for very specific things all the way
down at the bottom like clicks and
tracked events in this case
now that presumes that you understand a
little bit about the API that you're
trying to use
fortunatelly must most of it have many
of them I should say most of them have
decent documentation this example is
from the Star Wars API so in this case
you can
across the left the kinds of information
you can learn from this documentation
there's a getting started guide here in
the first page but the things that you
need to understand are there resources
towards the bottom and so that you know
what you can get and how to get it
for example this being the Star Wars API
you can get information about people
film
starships planets vehicles etc and the
beauty of this documentation is
particular documentation is very good so
it will tell you exactly what URL to use
to get to that information and it will
give you an example response as well so
it will tell you how to ask the question
and what format the answer will be in so
that you can then parse it appropriately
in your script the important part here
is that you need to learn that this
learn this API contract in order to use
it effectively you need to know how to
ask the question and how the answer will
be sent back to you
fortunately again these documentation
examples are often quite good because
they want you to be able to use it
successfully as well so to access these
API s and pull this information into are
you have a couple of different options
in some cases people have already
written packages that will wrap those
API calls for a given service the
examples I provided here or for AWS s3
this is s3 buckets and the Amazon Web
Services universe our Google Analytics
will get you information about Google
Analytics based on the the ID code that
you have for your website ACS is for the
American census information etc so some
people have already wrapped these API
into packages that are very easy to use
you do I mean if you can use them by all
means do they make your life a lot
easier you do need to be aware that the
people writing them may not have the
same goals as you do so they've written
it to solve their problem and then mid
of public but if you have other
questions that you need to ask or if
there's particular endpoints that aren't
covered in that package you may need to
write that yourself or there could be no
package for the data source that you're
trying to reach in which case you'll
write yourself with some other tools
I recommend HTT our or hitter for making
the requests
and then JSON light or XML - for parsing
the response
the most common response formats of API
calls are JSON and XML and these two
packages are extremely good at parsing
that data for you once you have the data
in use in your script you can you can
wrangle the data as a way that you
normally do with data that comes in
using the various packages in the tidy
verse to get your data in an orderly
rectangle so that you can use it for
your analyses and for your plots so here
our request functions wrap HTTP verbs
and fortunately they match them so
they're very easy to to figure out guess
is the one you'll probably be using the
most commonly if you're interested in
getting information from the web into
your scripts post is to write back to a
data store of some kind patch and put R
for updating delete is fairly obvious
and head is identical to get but without
the body so in this case you just be
getting the metadata around the request
without getting the body data this can
be useful as you're developing to
understand sort of everything around the
data itself in a much cheaper call so to
make a request you first load hitter it
with the library function then call get
to the URL in this case I am using the
Star Wars API
I'm calling planets with ID 1 so what
I'm trying to do here is get information
about planet number 1 in the Star Wars
API database and this will give you an a
response object if you print that out
you get some really useful information
the actual URL that was used after any
redirects the HTTP status the file or
content type and the size of that
response and we'll talk a little bit
more about how to use that later so you
can use various helpers and hitter to
dig into the response object for example
the status code helper will pull out
just code itself 200 is what you want to
see that means ok successful anything
else may be a problem that you would
need to handle in your code using the
headers
a helper will get you everything all the
metadata that came around through the
header of the response date content type
connection transferred coding etc is
quite a bit there and then what most
people area is interested in is the body
itself this is the content of the
response and so you would use the
content function from hitter to pull
that out and here I'm just looking at
the structure of it so you can see that
it is a list into the various amounts of
data to come back you'll see some of it
is nested some of it is URLs you're
going to need to understand all this in
order to handle it appropriately in your
scripts so there are three main parts
that you'll probably be most interested
in in your HTTP response the first is
status you can get these status the full
status information with the HTTP status
function it'll tell you all of
everything that it possibly can about
the status in most cases you're only
interested in the code so the status
code sorry object will come back with
just the number that you can to make
decisions in your code based on that
number in most cases you can
automatically throw a warning or raise
an error if ever succeed if it was not
200 with the warn for status and stop
for status helpers in the header package
I highly recommend these they convert
HTTP errors into our errors making them
much easier to handle in your script and
they'll either warn or stop just as they
as they imply the second of the
components that you want to be
interested that you want to handle are
the headers themselves date content
types
connection allow things like that there
can be custom headers in here it really
depends on the API that you are working
with the one that you're probably be
using most often is the content type
most api's have a pretty consistent
content type in their response in this
case they're using JSON so you may only
have to worry about this once but if
you're calling an unfamiliar API or
you're calling an API that changes
frequently it may behoove you to take a
look at that content type to make sure
that what you're parsing in your script
matches what you're being sent
you can also get cookies if you're
interested really depends on your API or
your what you're trying to get out of it
but the thing again but most people are
interested in is the body you use the
content function and hitter to get the
response body in this case you pass it
your object and a modifier so in this
case I want a character vector so I'm
going to pass in the word text and it
will give me back all of that
information that we just saw earlier in
the structure output if you have non
text responses you can get the raw
content with the raw modifier or you can
give it the parse this hitter has some
default parcels for common file types
including JSON XML and a couple of
others this can be really useful if if
you want a quick and dirty look at it
but honestly I tend to want to give the
the the parse I want to do the parsing
explicitly and so I don't tend to use
this very often but it's there if you
want it so let's turn now to some
examples here I've got some examples
from the Star Wars universe
see if I can make them a little bigger
for you great so this I'm going to be
working with a Star Wars API in these
examples and we're just going to walk
through some of the basics of how to
deal with api's in our first thing i'm
going to do is pull in hitter json light
because i know that the response is
going to be in JSON and recruiter for
piping to make it easier to read the
code as i'm passing this data around and
our first goal is to get the data for
the planet Alderaan
so the components of this request in
hitter are the same as they are in HTTP
you need a verb or a method in this case
get a URL endpoint to hit in this case
we're looking for planets and a
parameter here we're going to use search
not all API points endpoints need
parameters but in this case I'm
explicitly going to do a search and in
this API the key value pair is search
and then your text that you want to
search on so if I run this
you'll see that the hitter method get'
is in use is very straightforward it's
very readable and I can take a look at
that in a second but I also wanted to
point out here but there are different
ways to do your parameters if you have
many parameters if you've got six
parameters this URL gets crazy long and
hard to read so there's another format
you can use with the get method where
you pass in a query list and you give it
your key value pairs in that list we
don't need to do that here since I've
only got one but it's worth pointing out
especially if you're if you're looking
for a very detailed data that has a lot
of parameters in the in the search query
or in the set of parameters you're
sending to the API so now that I have
that data I'm going to take a look at
the data frame names and I've got URL
status code headers cookies the content
itself in the request and things like
that I'm getting back a lot of
information from this API which is great
I'm going to take a look specifically at
the status code this is a 200 excellent
that means it's exceeded and then I'm
going to take a look at the headers
specifically the content type in its
JSON which is what we expect again if
you're looking at an API that you don't
know very well these fields can help you
quite a bit in terms of deciding how to
to handle the data that comes back now
if I want the text of the response I'm
going to use the content method and
hitter half of the object I just created
tell it to give me text and specify the
encoding header will default to utf-8
but it throws a little warning so I
would usually just go ahead and put it
in there explicitly if you take a look
at the resulting object it's giving you
a count and next a previous and the
results themselves and this is
continuing the data that you're
interested for the most part it's not
very easy to read and it's not very easy
to get that data back out it's not very
are formatted at the moment so we're
going to need to parse this you can do
so with header as I mentioned earlier so
if you passed that into the content
method with the parsed modifier here you
can
I'm going to go ahead and run that and
then I'll take a look at it it's easier
to read them this is up here but it's
harder to get it but it's not
necessarily easy to get to some of the
information in the results themselves so
the count is pretty straightforward and
the results if you take a look at the
structure it's what we would expect it
all looks fine you've got some nested
elements here under presidents and films
and those are actual links to those
which makes it really really easy to get
that data programmatically so it's all
there and it's all usable and it's great
but in order to access this stuff it's a
little bit ugly in terms of this code at
the end of the world I've seen worse but
it's not always that easy to figure out
kind of how that structure works so I
use JSON light to parse this instead the
JSON light package so I'm going to take
that text content that we had up here
you can see that down here in the
console you have this I'm going to pass
that to the from JSON function in JSON
light and what this is going to do I
just ran that code and then we're going
to look at those objects again gives you
the count in the next in the previous
and we'll talk about that in a second
but the results are much easier to
handle in my opinion there's certainly
much easier to handle than this so now
that you've got that parsed in JSON
content I'm going to look specifically
at the results and get the names and now
it's a standard rectangular object that
we can deal with a lot more easily and
when you want to pull that data out this
code is a lot easier to work with lies
or to read in my opinion this code up
here so I do tend to use JSON light just
to make my life easier and also to you
know when I come back to this code in a
couple of months I don't necessarily
remember how I got that but it's really
easy to figure out how I got that so
JSON like big fan so I do this all the
time I do this every day
43,000 times a day and I don't want to
rewrite the same code so I wrote myself
a little helper function here and all it
does
is run the code take the content
function on the response tell it to
bring out back the text encoded if it's
empty warned if it's not run it through
from JSON so we can see how that looks
here in this case I'm going to get all
of the planets and stop for status again
we talked about that a little bit
earlier this is going to stop the script
if I get anything other than a 200 so
I'll go ahead and run that and I'll get
all the planets and then I'll json.parse
them and now I have JSON planets again
we have a count the next to the previous
results every API is going to differ a
little bit in this case this API is
telling me how many results came back
there how many folks are available
rather that's the count next is going to
be a link to the next page of results
previous is going to be the link to the
previous page of results and results is
the data itself so you'll notice here
I'm going to run the JSON planets count
and there's 61 planets in this data set
but if you look at the lengths of the
results that I just got back it's only
ten this API pages and that is not
uncommon you'll get your results back in
pages rather than the whole shebang for
performance reasons you can imagine
asking an API to send you a million
results it's not going to want to give
them to you all at once because it would
take down their servers so this API like
other API does page but you'll see if
you look at the next object it gives you
the link for the next page so in theory
you could page through these to get all
of your results into a single data frame
and that's what we're going to do down
here actually so that was the next page
I'm also going to take a look at the
results themselves so here I did the
JSON planets themselves take a look at
the results and then get the names of
the planets and so we'll get these first
ten planets that are in the database so
if I want to get the next page of
results it's really easy just to put the
object itself as the target of the get
function again stopping for status you
don't even have to like yearning that to
store it all you have to do
just pass it in and it will go get that
next page at this URL that it already
has in that object so if we run this the
next page will will actually I'm going
to parse it as well excuse me see parse
it and then I'm going to take those
results get the name this is the next
ten planets in the database so now I've
got the first page Senate story at
slappy planets and now I've got the
parsed next page that has the next set
of pages of the next set of data so if
your API results come back page like
this you can write a loop to follow the
next URL and so there are no more pages
are buying all the data into a single
data frame and have one big data frame
full of all this data it's not always
what you want to do but it's awfully
convenient when you have small data sets
there's only 61 planets so there's no
reason not to do that again this will
depend on the design of your API not all
of them are quite this nice not all of
them have those next and previous links
the way this one does but if it does you
may as well take advantage of it so here
I've written a little bit of code to
grab all of the starwars planets that
are available first I'm going to get the
first page of results staff or status
parse them and put them into an object
that I'm going to call swappi planets
Star Wars API planets based on those
results then the next page I am going to
assign to the the next object and while
that is not null go get the next page
dot for status parse and are bind it
back into the sloppy planets then reset
next page this API is very nice if there
is no next page you'll get a null which
is why I'm able to do the is null there
are other ApS that I've worked with that
aren't quite this nice they don't tell
you when you're on the last page and
that can it but it results in some more
involved code than we're talking about
here but we're very lucky in this case
this API is quite nice in that regard
again this all goes back to you needing
to know your API very well before you
start writing a lot of this but once you
do this code is only a couple of lines
of code that just run and I've now got
all 61 planets into
one object and I didn't have to do it by
hand and I didn't have to download a CSV
and re-import it into our and every
single time I run this it's going to
give me the most visit most up-to-date
planets if there are five more planets
that get added between today and
tomorrow when I run this tomorrow I will
then have 66 results and I can pipe that
into whatever data scripts that I would
like so this has just been a very kind
of simple example of how powerful these
tools can be in real life as I mentioned
earlier you know you're going to have to
handle some other cases for example if
you're if you're paging API doesn't tell
you when it's on the last page errors
that may get thrown headers proxy write
limits sometimes the AP actually most
times api's have rate limits so you can
only call a given API on certain number
of time per second a number of times per
second or per minute or per hour
depending on the API you call any more
than that they'll throw an error and
that's just to keep people from
overloading their servers you're going
to need to know how to handle that if
that happens within your script and
handle it appropriately so it doesn't
crash your application for more
information on the methods that are
sorry the functions that are available
to help you with this sort of thing you
can get help on the hitter package and
if you are actually interested in Star
Wars data at all which you know you
should be somebody did already write a
package for this API so you can see you
can you can work with it directly if you
like but you can also use this other
package but somebody has already written
around this particular API so then what
happens if your API requires
authentication so I've got two other
examples here there's a Twitter example
which uses OAuth 1 and there's a kid hub
issue or sorry it github example that
uses OAuth 2 these scripts are very
similar because the hitter package has
some really nice helpers to be able to
handle not only OAuth in general but
some common some common services like
Twitter and github and Facebook and
things like that there's an OAuth end
point method that takes values for the
use most common musical most comments
versus in this case Twitter is covered
so you you need to declare that you are
working with Twitter as your OAuth end
point then in Twitter itself you would
register a new application that this
script will talk to and you set the
callback URL to something very specific
bear in mind that this is this is an
example that hath li wrote up and it can
be found in the in the hitter demos if
you want if you need to come back and
refer to this but at any point you need
to set up the endpoint the first time
around and register the at the
application and associate that
application with the OAuth endpoints
that you just created so here we are
setting up an application or we are
setting up a reference to the
application you just created into a
Twitter we're giving it a name and the
key and the secret that were generated
when you set up this application in
Twitter this is going to allow this
application or the script to talk to the
application you just created in Twitter
now in real life you would not put your
key in secret right in your script
that's bad practice you would set that
up as an environment variable to keep
them out of the code but in this case it
is a test application so I just left it
in here for simplicity once you have
that set up you can use the OAuth 1
token function to associate the app you
just created with the endpoints that
Hitler already knows about because
Twitter is a known service so you use
that what you're trying to do here or
what you are doing here is generate a
token that uses the endpoint you've
already set up and the application you
already set up to get a token that you
can use to make calls authenticated
calls the first time you run this you're
going to be asked to authenticate to
approve this application or the scripts
use of this application once you've done
that as long as you have cash equals
true you shouldn't have to do it again
until that token expires the token
expiration is really up to the API I
don't remember what it is for Twitter
but I don't have to do this very often
at all when I give these demos so now
that you have a token you can actually
use it to make a request again we'll use
the get function what I'm trying to get
here is
the rstudio tips from the timeline and
I'm going to pass it that token that I
just generated so let's see is this a
little friend for me staffer status
again we're really looking for two
hundredths we did give it two hundred or
this would have thrown an error I'm
going to pull out the content using the
content function and hitter and then I'm
going to take a look at the first one
which isn't actually a tip it must have
been a response but at any rate you can
see how this works once you've set up
this Twitter token you can use it for as
long as it lasts again that's up to the
Twitter API I'm not sure how long that
lasts but you only have to run steps one
through you only have to run steps one
and two once and you should only have to
run step three periodically based on the
API then you can run as many requests as
you want to within the throttling limits
the github example is basically the same
just using the different method because
this o off to again you're going to set
up the endpoints and the app again you
would not put this in your code you
would put it in your environment
variables but it's there for simplicity
you'd set up your application in github
itself and then tell this script to call
that application that you just set up
based on the key in secret use the OAuth
2 token method
sorry function to associate the
endpoints with the application just set
up again it will ask you to authorize on
the application side saying is this
script okay to use this application you
should only have to do that once but if
you have cash equals true and then you
can use the API itself so we'll set up
the configuration pass that in to the
get request this is just another way to
set up a configuration by the way over
here in Twitter
we passed config token Twitter token
directly into the requests but rather
than writing that a bunch of times in
this case we set up a special object
just for that configuration and that we
can pass that in to any of our get calls
and make requests
so I'm going to make a request stop for
status it was 200 excellent I'm going to
take a look at what the rate when it is
it's 5000 so that's probably 5000 per I
would guess permit it could be per
second I gotta go figure that out from
the API
I don't know this API as well as I could
at any rate this is also an example from
has Lee's demos so if you want to take a
look at these yourself and play around
with them a bit modify them this is just
a modified version of what he has
written up already so as you can see
authentication can be handled easily if
you depending on how you handle the stop
for status or for the warned for status
you can also have your script
automatically handle errors that come
back from your from your API calls so I
touched upon some of these earlier there
are some other considerations again
you'll really need to know your eye API
you'll need to know what it expects and
what it's going to send back to you
and you need to make sure that that
documentation is honest I know that
developers make the best effort to make
sure that those API documentation
examples are accurate but sometimes
things change
sometimes you happen to be looking at
the wrong version sometimes there are
mistakes so you just want to experiment
with it a little bit to figure out
exactly how how this is going to work if
you have to deal with paging which we
touch them a little bit as well as rate
limiting time to first buy this a little
trickier this is response time so in
some cases a PRS are not very fast so
you're going to have to figure out how
to deal with that in your script and how
to get around that whether or not you
need to wait for the response things
like that you may need to handle data
storage if you are putting this API
information into another data store for
you to analyze later and it's a good
idea to understand the hitter or
functionality that that augments the
things that we've already been talking
about so we did talk a bit about os1 and
os2 you can also use proxies and the
authenticate method itself is a little
more generic you can use it to
authenticate with basic authentication
and other kinds of tokens there are
requests the modifiers as well these
tend to come up in post methods rather
than in get messy
so this is when you're sending data to a
data store you can set cookies at
headers set contact type in the accept
headers as well and finally there's some
other just helpers that that make life a
little bit easier set for status and
warn for status we've already talked a
bit about you can also set a time out
again for those long response times you
can have it set to refer both which will
give you the lot more information about
the HTTP conversation requests in
response parsed URL progress things like
that so there's quite a bit in there I
would definitely recommend taking a look
at the vignettes in the hitter package
in the cran and finally I wanted to tell
you a bit about a practical application
so this is what I work on every day I
spend a lot of time analyzing support
tickets to identify product improvements
documentation enhancements process
improvements things like that I want to
know how the user experience can form
the improvements of our products so I
spend a lot of time and are crunching
the data around support tickets this
application is in two parts the first
part is an R script that gets support
ticket data via API and puts it into an
s3 bucket and the second part is where
various applications and reports pull
that data from s3 and then run those
analyses so the reason I have this in
two parts is because our support ticket
tools API is quite slow and I have to
page through a lot of data and pull that
into a single data frame the way that we
did with that Star Wars API data takes a
lot of effort and it takes a lot of time
because these API calls are not quick so
if I asked somebody who is loading an
app or a report to sit there and wait
for five minutes all that data comes
back they would close the window they
wouldn't do it so in this case I have
two different parts and I've traded real
time access for application load time in
this case it doesn't really matter what
we're looking at here is historical
trends so we don't necessarily need real
time data and so having this script run
once a day even
or five times a day and push that data
into s3 allows the application itself to
just make one call to that s3 bucket
pull it back really quickly so we've
traded that off another alternate
approach might be to make a series of
incremental API calls that update the
apps as the data comes in but we didn't
think that was necessary for this
particular application which is why we
have it into two parts so the first part
pulls that data filters tidies flattens
it using the tiny verse saves it to an
s3 bucket and we have deployed that
script to our studio konnekt and
scheduled it to pull the api to update
the data store automatically I never
touched that unless I want a different
set of data unless I want to augment the
data it's beautiful it runs
automatically every night I don't have
to worry about it every morning my tea
reports are brand-new and up-to-date the
second part are those applications and
reports that pull that data from s3 and
visualize that information and again we
use this data to to make things better
maybe a quick look at what that oh
excuse me a quick look at what this ends
up looking like hang on a second let me
regenerate that for you it's a little
large there we go so this is an example
of this is real data from our support
tickets and this is how we have been
using this data that we're pulling from
an API on this first one is ticket
volume for the past two years blue is
created and orange is solve so we're
solving them as fast as they're being
filed which is a good thing over here on
the right is ticket volume by-product
for this last year so we can take a look
at which products are getting the most
stickers filed and potentially target
those for improvements prioritize them
rather for improvements down here a
year-over-year volume by week our
patterns are very similar although the
volume was less this year was higher
than last as one would expect as we have
more more people using it and over here
we have categories of tickets so things
like installation or configuration or
affect an actual bug that someone found
and may graph those over time as well so
that we can tell we're category to need
the most love in the products and things
like that so this is a really practical
application that we use in-house every
day to figure out where we can target
improvements based on information that
we're pulling in from a couple of
different API is actually that we pull
together using the tools that I have
just described
so to recap I can't emphasize enough how
useful a PRS are especially for datasets
that are updated regularly again I don't
touch that script we deployed it to
connect and it runs every night without
me touching it and pulls all that data
in by itself based on the code that I've
written to handle that API very easy to
pull that data in keep it up to date
with the right packages and tools you
are going to have to do some works
around you know the API contract to make
sure you understand what's coming back
and to handle errors and things like
that but once you get it in place it's
very easy to maintain and once you have
that data in or you can do all sorts of
wonderful things like with it in our
case we're making business decisions off
of it so it's pretty exciting stuff if
you want more information there's more
information on APA pis and HTTP itself
in these two links these two links are
also available in Hadleys getting
started vignette four-hitter so you
don't feel you have to snag it here
although I think these slides will be
available online for the webinars later
and if you need more information on the
tools themselves you can always run the
help function there's a really great
documentation there haffley's QuickStart
vignette vignette I've mentioned before
and his demos in the master in his in
the repo and the github repo this JSON
light vignettes are also really really
helpful I assume there's also XML two
vignettes that I neglected to look up
but I assume you can find them as well
if your data is coming back as XML and
then the the last one here is a really
interesting vignette on how to use this
information to write your own package to
access an API if you have an API out
there where you have an internal API for
that matter and you want to write a
package to make it easier for people to
access this information that has
error-handling built-in things like that
this vignette gives some best practices
for how to do that finally if you have
any questions that aren't answered here
you're always welcome to to write to me
directly I'm Amanda at our studio comm
well thank you so much Amanda that was
terrific our audience has any questions
please use the question box in the
system to pose those now but as we wait
for that are there any other data
sources that you would recommend for our
experimentation something sure sure
well I'm very partial to the Star Wars
API as you can tell there are a couple
of other ones as well there's one called
om GD which we touched on briefly at the
beginning that's the online movie
database it's like an open source
version of IMDB and it's very structured
like this is so you can play around with
that very easily without worrying about
too many too many frustrations in the
API there's also one called
HTTP bin org HTTP bi n org and that is a
very simple simple way to test your
these different methods out with very
simple responses it is very very
bare-bones but it's a great way to get
sort of some extent practice and their
documentation is excellent as well
[Music]